nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman so in the aftermath of the
january 6th
trump riots and the hundreds and
hundreds of arrests and starting to see
uh the processing into the court system
of some of the
uh alleged criminals the rioters one of
the questions that we've discussed in
one of the questions that's come up
is not only what are these individuals
going to be charged with
but what would prosecutors be able to
prove and some of the
most serious charges that could be
levied against some of these individuals
would be charges of sedition and as we
said when we talked about this
maybe a month ago maybe six weeks ago at
this point as some of these cases were
starting to be built
was that sedition much like perjury
can be obvious colloquially
and yet very difficult to prove in a
court of law because you do need to be
able to
demonstrate beyond a reasonable doubt
that the
mindset of the perpetrator is knowable
and that you can say this was their
intent when they in the case of perjury
said something that was untrue under
uh said something untrue under oath and
meant to overthrow the government when
they were participating in the trump
riots well
it appears as though prosecutors at
least in some of these cases believe
that they can do that
because there's a new new york times
report from just the last few hours
which says that quote
evidence the government obtained in the
investigation into the january 6th
attack on the capital
most likely meets the bar necessary
to charge some of the suspects with
sedition
according to michael sherwin a federal
prosecutor who's been leading the
justice department's
inquiry this was from an interview
yesterday the department
has rarely brought charges of sedition
writes the new york times
the crime of conspiring to overthrow the
government but in an interview with 60
minutes
sherwin said quote i personally believe
the evidence is trending toward that
and probably meets those elements i
believe the facts
do support those charges and i think
that as we go forward
more facts will support that this is
obviously not going to be the charge for
most of the hundreds of people that are
going to be charged or have been charged
here
but it appears as though some will be
and this is major it's been 11
years you have to go back to 2010 for
the last time that there was a federal
charge of sedition and that was a charge
against
a michigan militia of plotting
to provoke an armed conflict with the
government
in order to overthrow it they were
ultimately acquitted
and back then and this is this goes to
mindset
the judge in the michigan case from 2010
said that the justice department federal
prosecutors did not prove
the defendants were concretely
trying to oppose and overthrow the
united states
government so this is going to be i
don't want to say these are landmark
cases it seems hyperbolic but
this will be a really big deal because
now we have not only
writers inspired by trump not only
rioters and
inspired by the lies from trump and his
followers and
and others on the right that joe biden
stole the election as the reason that
they were doing this but we may see some
of these very very serious federal
charges
of uh sedition and it's going to take
some time for all of this to work
through
the system and to ultimately see what is
there now i think it's also important in
terms of expectation setting
even if there are charges of sedition
that doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to see trials with guilty
not guilty verdicts
deciding on sedition you could see some
of these
individuals rioters charged with
sedition
initially but then it never goes to
trial and there's a plea agreement where
they agree to plead guilty
uh to something lower and there's no
question i mean listen if you said it's
a numbers game if you see 10 sedition
charges i don't know how many you'll see
if you see 10 sedition charges i would
imagine that the vast majority
seven eight you never get a trial
on sedition charges and an eventual not
guilty verdict i think most of them
uh you you get they get played down and
part of the reason would be
i mean listen on both sides based on the
history of federal sedition charges
if you're the lawyer for one of these
rioters
you understand that although it may not
be likely to be found guilty on sedition
it's a very big hill to climb for the
federal prosecutors
that if your client was guilty of
sedition it would be really bad so you
may go to them and say listen it's
really in our interests
not to put this uh to trial and you may
have a rioter who's more likely to
accept
a plea on some lesser charge if you're
the prosecutor's even i mean listen even
if you feel
pretty good about a sedition charge if
it's not bulletproof as far as you're
concerned
it's also a risk to you to put that to
trial
and possibly get an acquittal and end up
getting nothing
against some of these rioters so it's we
may see the charges
the attorney said the prosecutor says
that he believes there's evidence
for it uh a sedition charge on some of
these cases
but i think if you get it both sides
would be well incentivized
uh to plea to to to plead it down and i
wouldn't be at all shocked if
very few or even none of the sedition
charges ever actually go to trial where
you get a determination
of guilt or lack of guilt on a sedition
charge i could be wrong
we're going to follow it that's the
latest we know as of right now
president joe biden who some on the left
framed as a neo-liberal warmonger
thirsty for wars and colonialism around
the world
wants to completely re-examine and
evaluate
the global troop presence of the united
states and maybe decrease it in some
significant way and
what's interesting about this story it's
not been getting a lot of attention
and it's not surprising to me that it's
not getting a lot of attention because
this is the exact type of story
that does terribly when we talk about it
because the sensible left is sort of
like
yeah we sort of knew that biden wasn't a
bloodthirsty warmonger so this isn't
surprising
the antibiden left just doesn't want to
hear it because it runs counter
to their narrative and it's really what
the right expects i mean
i know that the right under trump
cheered this talking point of trump
didn't
start any new wars but it's not actually
their preferred position on foreign
policy the preferred position
of the reactionary right is democratic
presidents are weak
because they don't want to use the
military and they often want to shrink
the military that's the lane
in which the right is most comfortable
critiquing democratic presidents
so the news is to start at the beginning
that the joe biden administration has
launched a full
systemic review of the global presence
of the us military
to ensure that it is quote correctly
sized and supports
strategy so at the top that's not the
language
of our military's presence is too small
and we should figure out ways to make it
much bigger
that's kind of the starting point
foreign policy analysts believe that
this is exactly the type of review
that could lead to recommendations to
reduce the number
of bases abroad something i've been
talking about for a decade
reduce the number of troops deployed
around the world now of course
we should all be skeptical that it will
turn into action
given two things number one given all of
the different ways that republicans can
obstruct
uh we have to wonder whether even a
recommendation of reducing the us global
troop presence will turn into into a
reality
on the other hand we've also heard this
from other presidents right i mean we we
heard this from obama
we've even heard it from republican
presidents and rarely do things
change dramatically right now the u.s
has about 800 quote bases around the
world
it's an incredible top-line number the
truth is that includes some
very small outposts that few of us would
see a picture of and say that's a base
all the way up to massive complexes with
thousands of troops and their families i
mean just huge installations
germany is a place where there are many
there are some in italy
many of these are essentially vestiges
of the cold war
that we really don't need and arguably
are a detriment to american foreign
policy
and for me this is not just a moral
issue although it is one
but it's also an economic issue we talk
about tax rates and how
we can afford things that some want to
do
putting aside for a second modern
monetary theory
and a more uh nuanced understanding of
debt and deficit and putting aside the
macroeconomic discussion
the micro of the budget is not trivial
half of american discretionary spending
is on military and defense
so we can talk about tax rates of course
and last week we talked about okay
do should we raise taxes on people
making over 400 000 or over a million or
over 2 million where should it be
but imagine without changing anything
about taxation taxation
what we could afford with current tax
revenues
if we change spending priorities and
reduce the amount
that we're spending on defense and the
military and without a doubt that
there's a huge i'll believe it when i
see it component as i mentioned
earlier but this is sort of like a
wow uh uh what what is the truth
of biden's foreign policy and to be
clear this
is not a wow biden is the super
progressive on foreign policy
absolutely not that's not what i'm
saying the point here is
just like some on the left insisted
hillary would have started five new wars
and there was really no reason to
believe that that's what would happen
the people expecting biden to do the
same and to grow
the troop presence are going to be
disappointed now
joe biden did decide to pause and
re-examine
troop withdrawals that were started or
at least announced by donald trump i'm
talking about
afghanistan and germany where trump said
let's pull out and joe biden got in and
said we're going to pause that
let's wait and see okay because the
position of the biden administration is
essentially
these are my words not theirs but this
is the way i understand it
trump was so incompetent that it's worth
reviewing everything trump was in the
middle of before we decide whether
to continue it my hope is that biden
reviews
those two withdrawals germany and
afghanistan and does this bigger
reevaluation and says let's continue
and then let's do more at the same time
troops in germany is far less
controversial than many other
deployments
and so i think that the u.s has a
comically high number of bases in
germany
and many of them are completely
unnecessary i don't know that i would
have
would have started in germany
necessarily when i think about reducing
our troop spread around the world
doesn't matter the point is we're going
to wait and see what joe biden
actually decides on those two we're also
going to see what the outcome is
of this systemic review of the global
troop presence around the world and
listen i'm not i know some people will
write to me and say david you're so
naive
he's not doing anything the point is
there was a narrative
about biden's gonna start all these new
wars
he's going to be the neo-liberal you
know a dominionist of some kind
there was never any evidence of that and
so far what we're seeing is also
not indicative of that if you disagree
with me let me know you can find me on
twitter at deepakman
and this friday it's finally time
this friday march 26th we are doing a
one-day membership bonanza we're looking
for
massive dumps of new memberships to make
up for a really crappy
february if you want to be notified of
this one day membership special it's
very easy
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
friday you'll get an email telling ever
telling you everything you need to know
and probably even some things you don't
need to know
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different
experience than any other shower head
i've used i can get in and out of the
shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed
that it's only using about half as much
water
nebia also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products remember that the
david pakman show is made
possible by members like you who sign up
at
joinpackman.com we have a new
unpublished secret coupon code the
coupon code is
immoral 21 because it's an immoral
discount
my staff has been telling me david it's
too cheap
you shouldn't do it the morals are in
question and i said no guys we're going
to do it
and that coupon code is immoral 21 you
can sign up
at joinpakman.com one of the things i do
on this program
is i tell you honestly and directly when
a political issue
is merely a political football and has a
public-facing debate that is
essentially meaningless now one such
issue that is a political football
is debt and deficit we've talked about
it endlessly republicans claim to care
about debt and deficit
until a republican is president and then
when george w bush blows up the deficit
when donald trump blows up the deficit
they say nothing and then now they're
back on it because joe biden is
president it's a meaningless political
football
it doesn't get into the meat of when is
national debt
good bad problematic interest on the
debt japan china holders of the debt you
know all these different things doesn't
get to it it's just a meaningless
political football
it's a deflated football we could call
it
another such political football whose
public debate is meaningless
is gas prices now if you've been
listening to our podcast for a while if
you've been watching this show for some
time
you know i never played into this my
position
whether the president is a republican or
a democrat is
presidents have some but relatively
little to do with gas prices
over the long term and you can fact
check me on this go back and check out
my clips during past presidents
and you will find that i've been
consistent i don't play
the gas price games whether it's during
trump in 2018 in a clip called
gas prices hit three-year high where i
say
this has little to do with trump it's
mostly seasonal
or you go back to 2015 under barack
obama
in a clip called dollar 99 gas returns
where i say
this really doesn't have to do much with
barack obama
there are probably about a dozen or so
clips that we've done
about this issue in general gas prices
go up in the summer when demand is
higher
they go down in the winter when demand
is lower in general
global supply issues rather than an
american president
impact gas prices and right now gas
prices are up
about 18 to 20 percent over the last few
months and very quickly once again
you are starting to see the hot takes
blaming joe biden
and the story that they are telling is
trump kept gas prices low
joe biden came in and gas prices have
skyrocketed now
neither is true in a causal way and
we're going to look at it
but some examples the official
republican twitter account tweeting
quote
president biden's energy agenda will
raise
gas prices even higher by shutting down
american energy production that's not
true here's republican house minority
leader
and it gives me great pleasure to remind
you he's the minority leader kevin
mccarthy
including gas prices in his sort of
grievance list against joe biden just a
few days ago
look what has happened in the short
amount of time they've controlled all
your gasoline price is up biden's
created
a crisis on the border that he won't
admit
there was also a widely shared facebook
post whose basic message was
when sleepy joe came in diesel was a
dollar sixty-nine
today diesel is 319. thanks to all that
voted for this clown
now the numbers are wrong in that post
but the causality is also gone so i
could go on and on with more examples
but here's the truth this has nothing to
do with joe biden
and it started before joe biden was
president
first of all gas prices move on a delay
in response to oil supply issues it's a
much slower process
than some republicans want you to think
right now
and in this case we know why gas prices
are up it's the inverse reason of why
they were down in 2020.
the price of oil and thus gasoline
collapsed in 2020 due to no
demand it costs money to store oil
and when demand for gas is down you
don't necessarily
want to keep refining oil at the same
clip
because there's not demand for it so you
store the oil and demand was down
so much due to the pandemic people not
flying people not
commuting cruise industry shutdown that
the price of oil and gas collapsed
now as vaccination is rolling out as
cases are declining
as air travel is returning as commuting
is returning demand is increasing
and it's actually in some areas
increasing very quickly
so gas prices are going up globally it's
not just in the united states
this has nothing to do with joe biden
but then here's the cherry on top
many republican talking points require
not understanding how time exit time
works or believing in time travel
if you look at a chart of gas or diesel
prices here's a chart of diesel prices
up on the screen you will notice
the increase started in october under
donald trump
and it simply continued during trump's
presidency in november
in december the first two thirds of
january then joe biden took over
and the gas and diesel price increase is
continuing and it is
related to demand coming back
as the pandemic hopefully starts to wane
don't fall for this stuff it'll rot your
brain
as uh as as i like to say and it's not
borne out
by the facts it's not borne out by the
data
it is not joe biden's fault that gas
prices are up and
importantly gas prices being up is a
good sign
that demand is returning and hopefully
if we keep vaccinating
if we start getting vaccines to more
countries more quickly and we continue
vaccinating more quickly
um we will we will see significant
economic improvements that yes might go
with
uh you know a tank of gas costing a few
dollars more for the average
consumer vehicle new yorker writer
jane mayer gave an interesting interview
to npr's terry gross a few days ago
and the topic was whether donald trump
might end up being the first president
to ever be criminally charged now as
i've said before
i maintain and believe that donald trump
will
never see the inside of a prison cell
some people write to me and they tell me
i'm wrong
well i mean we can't say i'm wrong yet
it hasn't happened yet
some people write to me and say david
when you say that it makes it less
likely trump will go to prison i don't
think me saying it makes it any less
likely
but the fact that i don't think trump
will ever see the inside of a prison
cell doesn't mean he won't be charged
and as jane mayer points out in this
interview with npr which you can find
online
there are a number of viable paths to
donald trump ending up with criminal
charges against him being the first
president to have such charges against
him
right now we know of two possible
criminal charges
investigations with possible criminal
charges coming the first
is the investigation in georgia over
donald trump's now
known multiple phone calls trying to get
election results changed
in the 2020 georgia presidential
election the second one
and the one that actually predates the
georgia probe is the one led by
manhattan district attorney
cyrus vance which is looking at trump's
financial practices
and in that one tax banking insurance
fraud
all on the table and that's the one
where
uh they finally got a decision from the
supreme court that indeed trump's
financial records
must be turned over and they have been
so now cyrus vance has those records now
as i've said before the most likely
scenario
is some kind of financial charges
probably against
others at the trump organization but
still
it's possible donald trump could be
criminally charged
in that investigation jane mayer
addresses
many of the important questions for
example terry gross
asks her whether even if trump committed
crimes
we should just move on because trump is
gone and jane mayer points out
listen it's true that lots of the
countries
that charge former leaders with crimes
are not necessarily the countries we're
trying to emulate but
she argues that if the crimes trump
committed aren't even related to the
presidency
these are business crimes for example
what reason is there not to pursue them
pursue them and this is an important
point we know that every president makes
decisions that lead to deaths
but we don't charge presidents in those
cases because it would make being
president impossible i'm not saying
that i'm against war crimes charges
that's not at all what i'm saying but
every time you cut aid or shift military
resources
send troops into war change some welfare
program do a drum strike
every presidency leads to civilian
deaths some of which could have been
avoided right or wrong
u.s presidents don't get charged with
that stuff and we can have a debate
about that but that's not what we're
talking about here
if we find out trump was laundering
money through his business
who cares if he was president for a
four-year period
it's unrelated to him being president
and there shouldn't be a culture of
impunity as
jane mayer correctly points out the
possible financial crimes
and fraud in new york are significant
taking tax deductions on things that
aren't tax deductible to the tune of
millions of dollars
including even some of those hush money
payments that donald trump made
exaggerating or diminishing the claimed
value of real estate
to manipulate lenders and taxation
authorities to his benefit
there's a very long list here and these
are crimes in the state of new york
on the tail end of this the question of
prison comes up
are the things being investigated
theoretically punishable by prison time
yes would trump get prison time
even if found guilty it's possible
would he serve it i can't imagine jane
mayer says in the interview
she believes trump would flee the
country if he actually were
sentenced to prison time the truth is i
don't think that's very likely but we're
in such unprecedented territory that
it's very difficult to predict
my sense is the most likely scenario is
there's no prison time
and trump doesn't have to flee i still
believe that's the most
obvious and logical scenario the
importance to me of criminally charging
trump
isn't to put him in prison it's twofold
first it's to show that a president
isn't above the law
and maybe that will prevent another
president from being as corrupt and
criminal as donald trump
maybe that's naive but that's one
important element of this
secondly as a very practical matter if
there are criminal charges against
donald trump
it could just keep him too busy to even
think about running again in 2024 and
that would be a very good thing
we'll have more coverage of this on the
david pakman show
instagram you can follow us there at
david pakman show
follow me on instagram david.pacman if
you want to see
me um what would be the right word and
that's not really accosted
smothered by a dog that doesn't
understand the concept of personal space
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
this is a fascinating segment that goes
to the limits of political loyalty
because there are some trump supporters
whose undying support for trump
has no limit but for some trump
supporters
their support of trump does have a limit
and that limit is called the coronavirus
vaccine you're gonna
be probably horrified by these clips
after a year of donald trump telling his
own supporters
that the pandemic isn't serious calling
it the china virus
that you don't need a vaccine some of
those trump supporters
now don't want the vaccine they see the
vaccine as liberal nonsense
especially as they see joe biden as the
one who is so quickly
accelerating vaccination nearly three
million doses the last two days we'll
talk about that tomorrow but that's very
good news
so cnn sends their reporter gary tuckman
to a diner
in boise city oklahoma and it
is compelling video this uh county
was a 92 percent trump county back in
november
but right now we have some conflicting
numbers we know that most republican
voters still like trump
but about half of republicans don't want
the vaccine as of last week trump now
recommends to his followers
that they get the vaccine so we have a
statistical conflict
they mostly like trump who's saying get
the vaccine but half of them
don't want the vaccine how does this
conflict manifest
gary tuckman asks the diners questions
about the vaccine
it got awkward and very ignorant let's
take a look at the first clip
it's breakfast time in boise city
oklahoma
and i have this question does anybody in
this restaurant think it's a good idea
to take the vaccine
no raise your hand if you think it's a
good idea
anyone here is a good idea to take the
vaccine raise your hand if you think
it's a good idea
not one person here thinks is a good
idea
complete quiet so that's already not so
good and then gary tuchman speaks to
some specific people and here
i would get the kids out of the room for
this this is
ugly ugly stuff that we're about to see
take a look what do you think about the
vaccine are you going to take the
vaccine no sir
tell me why well i don't trust the
government and i don't trust biden
chad and misty hughes are husband and
wife neither of them plan to get the
vaccine
just don't want to why don't you if you
don't mind me asking
because when i take the flu shot i
usually get the flu so
there's no reason to take it are you
saying you think you'll get covered by
taking the cover detection
are you why are you thinking that the
research doesn't show that at all
it shows that it keeps people safe
that's just my choice
so that first guy is bad enough who says
i don't trust the government or
biden because remember the vaccine was
developed
not because of trump but it was
developed during trump's administration
trump is taking credit for it trump's
people initially oversaw
the initial distribution which was
completely abortive but still
like the first guy doesn't care now joe
biden is president
now is when that guy could get a vaccine
and he doesn't trust the government or
joe biden
but the second guy the flu shot usually
gives me the flu
it can't happen it's impossible doesn't
happen so i will assume that the covet
vaccine will give me covet
that's not necessarily a trump biden
thing
that's total vaccine ignorance that
appears to go beyond politics
although it seems to still exist more on
the right than on the left
let's look at another one of these
absolutely horrifying clips
these women are sisters and they too are
doubters
why are you doubtful they just started
rolling them out
well yeah but they've i mean this has
been a worldwide effort
by a great deal claim that the flu can
be cured
but still hundreds of thousands of
people die from the flu well
yes a lot of nearly as much as coving
this is a horrible pandemic and this is
like an
amazing vaccine these vaccines have come
out they're saving lives
no i will just agree to disagree on this
subject i guess
i just i'm just not i'm not gonna take
it she said
they claim the flu can be cured
but people still die of the flu despite
having a vaccine
so this is like it's the brain is
it's is it putty is it uh i don't know
what to call it
no one claims the flu vaccine cures flu
the idea is the flu vaccine
prevents flu in some and in others it
makes it less severe
but the flu vaccines are not nearly as
effective as these coronavirus vaccines
are
and if you wonder how does someone get
tricked by trump
into believing he's going to build a
wall and that mexico will pay for it
that'll fix trade that he'll put in a
beautiful health care plan
these are the same people that believe
the flu shot will give you the flu
right these are the people we're talking
about that fell for that stuff and were
tricked into voting for donald trump
here's another clip what if
president trump came out and was very
robust and said
take the vaccine i took it even though i
didn't tell anybody about it was kind of
done secretly but i think he should take
it
he said it a little bit but he hasn't
been robust about if he was robust and
said take it would you no
new yorker why would we listen to him
either
did you vote for him he was the best
option
what's funny about that trump voter who
says
trump's a liberal new yorker why would i
listen to him anyway
that antipathy that came out there that
cultural clash
the diners in oklahoma are like this guy
trump in the end is just like a rich
liberal new yorker that exists on
trump's behalf as well and what i mean
by that is
the vast majority of trump supporters as
i've said so many times
are the types of people that donald
trump spent his life
trying to stay away from so it's
fascinating stuff
but it is very disturbing to see these
clips and some of what these folks talk
about
you know it's like what's more dangerous
getting covet of the vaccine the answer
is obvious
getting covet is far more dangerous than
any side effects you would have from the
vaccine
another question is what's more
dangerous
getting the virus or being that ignorant
like what other risks to their lives
exist or are created because of the
degree of ignorance that they
exhibit during interviews like this it
is wacky wacky stuff
and you know i told the story last week
of i've spent time
in rural northern indiana and
while i don't agree with the political
views of the people there
seeing it and seeing how basically you
grow up
in a church and on a gun range that's
what there is in northern indiana
being told that guns and abortion are
the two most important things of course
you're not voting for democrats
because you're for for 18 years by the
time you can vote and longer by the time
you know
you're older that's all that you that's
all that's there and that's all that
that
is your experience of course you're not
going to vote for joe biden based on
what
what is publicly said we have to
understand these folks
because as ignorant as they are if they
don't get vaccinated it's bad for all of
us
and um unfortunately the the sort of
ignorance is bliss type of thing
it may work for them but it's still
dangerous for many others so interesting
interesting segment there gary tuckman
with cnn
you have to see this a fox news
propagandist and former
judge janine pirro cut off an interview
because she says she doesn't tolerate
lies on her show
that's beyond parrot like you can't make
an snl skit out of this
because the real segment is already an
snl skit
judge jeanine was interviewing an
immigration attorney named david leopold
he's a lawyer with ulmer and
bernie llp and it starts going south
when david leopold tells the judge that
not much of what he's hearing on her
show are facts
and this this starts to set her off take
a look two
that the highest number is because biden
is sending them in
janine just because you say my number
one doesn't mean they're wrong
and you want to talk about about their
facts
these are the facts they're not facts
very few things that i hear in the show
tonight have been facts
you said this evening that the border
was open well david let me ask
you something if you don't think
anything's benefit so she doesn't like
that
she starts shuffling around her papers
and such and then when david leopold
says
listen joe biden is actually the one
making america great again
she gets fully triggered she says
canceled she's ending the interview
because
she does not tolerate lies on her show
kept his promise he's putting common
relief out there
he's making america better he's making
america great again he is
bringing david i'm stopping you're right
there i don't tolerate lies on my show
he is bringing covent into this country
after americans weren't allowed to go to
work go to church
or visit families or go to funerals and
now he's bringing in a whole pandemic
during a pandemic david leopold thanks
for being here
and thanks for nothing thank you still
ahead mike
this is um this is the death of irony
judge jeanine on fox news
does not tolerate lies
you can't write this stuff and she truly
seems
flabbergasted and dismayed that
someone anyone would have the testicular
fortitude
to call her out on her own program now
my instinct is
that david leopold is not going to be
invited back
to judge jeanine's program notice also
that she didn't even allow a discussion
of whether what he was saying is a fact
which of course leopold
would have been able to defend had he
been given the opportunity but he was
it's all the stuff that the right says
they don't do she
silenced the battle of ideas and then
she
cancelled david leopold genuine problems
here
another media literacy education
epistemology problem
is that in this country the question of
what is a fact is being debated
now i don't mean by that that
the uh empirical particulars
of facts are being debated like that
would be a debate like oh
what is the number of parts per million
of carbon or carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere right like that that's we're
debating
the number okay we're not even debating
the relevance or consequences of a fact
many people in this country
quite literally don't know what type of
statement is in the realm of an
empirical
fact-checkable data point and what is an
opinion
in the anti-vax segment that i played
for you earlier
we heard people being told you can't get
the flu from the flu shot
you can't get covered from the coveted
vaccine that's an empirical question
where
we can find it out is there evidence of
people getting the flu from the flu shot
but then the people we saw say this is
my view of what is a fact
people do get the the flu from the flu
jack flu shot
we we are not in agreement as to what
types of things
are facts versus opinion and of course
fox news specializes in that by saying
well we have the opinion side
and we have the news side but they blur
it and then
they on the news side report on what the
opinion people say
as if they are facts this is what it
leads to
it leads to exactly this and um i don't
think we'll be seeing david leopold back
on judge jeanine's show and i know a
bunch of people said david
she seems drunk again yeah i don't know
i don't know i know that there's been a
number of episodes where judge jeanine
just
just really seems drunk either way she's
she's a disaster
uh it's not uh i i have no idea whether
she was or wasn't drinking but of
of the i think eight people sent me this
interview
six said she seems to be drunk again
maybe i don't know but what she's doing
the
you know the cancellation of david
leopold i don't think is
based on the amount that she's had to
drink let's take a quick break
we'll be back after this with much more
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous
at this point and the daily commercial
free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow occasionally fox news
host chris wallace will bring us some
kind of like heroic
journalism by american standards but
it's really what in other countries
would just be called
journalism and today's is perfect
because it shows us how easily a talking
point that spreads like wildfire
can be exposed and debunked if reporters
are actually willing to do it and many
many are not or at least they're they're
not well prepared enough to do it and
the talking point in this case
is that stimulus checks are going to
prisoners
republicans have among other things been
saying
democrats and joe biden are sending
stimulus checks to people
in prison and some senators
say it and then right wing media says it
and then before you know it it's being
repeated by
you know republican voters and diners
the likes of which we saw
in clips earlier today the truth of
course
is that prisoners got stimulus money
during the first covet stimulus package
and during the second covet stimulus
package it's how they work
it's not set up to exclude people who
are
otherwise income eligible just because
they're in prison now
maybe it could be done logistically but
a court has actually said no you can't
do it
and so radical republican senator tom
cotton
uh pulls this bullet point and chris
wallace confronts him
check out tom cotton's defense and chris
wallace
confronting tom cotton with his own
previous words here
here is one of your other complaints
about the
the covet relief bill take a look sir
look how crazy some of the democratic
ideas are i mean they had a chance on
saturday morning to stop checks from
going to prisoners
from going to the boston bomber for
instance and on that vote
they declined every single democrat
wanted to continue the practice of
sending checks to prisoners
but senator under two previous coped
relief bills that you
supported and voted for and that
president trump signed
prisoners also got checks in those bills
well chris that was obviously never
congress's intent the trump
administration irs and treasury
department
did not send checks to prisoners liberal
advocacy groups sued to try to force
that a liberal judge said they had to
last month was the for this month was
the first time we ever had a simple up
or down vote on whether those checks
should go to prisoners
and the simple fact is that every
democrat voted to keep sending checks to
prisoners
i don't think that's a smart idea i
suspect most americans don't either
so notice how tom cotton tries like a
mini gish gallop there
gish gallop is where you throw a bunch
of stuff out and it sort of altogether
sounds like wow that's a lot but then
when you start going through each claim
you realize there's nothing there
first tom cotton concedes okay yes
stimulus checks went to prisoners during
trump's
covet stimulus number one checks went to
prisoners during trump's coveted
stimulus number two
and now checks are going to prisoners
during the third stimulus under joe
biden but says tom cotton
during the first and second ones it
wasn't our
intent we didn't want them to go to
prisoners
this time democrats do want the checks
to go to prisoners it was never their
intention he says
but they did it twice and then they only
are making a big deal out of it
the third time when joe biden is
president and democrats control the
senate
but then tom cotton says this is the
first time we actually
had an up or down vote on it and it
passed well
that's because you guys controlled the
senate before
and you didn't want an up and down vote
but more importantly the up and down
vote this time was irrelevant
because it's already been decided on
previously by a federal judge
the irs inspector general previously
after
i i believe it was after the second
stimulus bill might have been the first
i think it was the second
the irs inspector general confirmed uh
that they did send checks to prisoners
during one of the earlier stimulus
packages
and because there were no restrictions
on people in jail or prison getting the
money
the irs later was pressured to change
their position
and the irs said you know what prisoners
don't qualify for the relief checks
and if anybody got one they should send
the money back so prisoners filed a
class-action lawsuit against the irs and
the treasury secretary
and a federal judge ruled on this in
september
the court ruling said you can't withhold
coronavirus relief payments
if prisoners qualify from an income
standpoint
just because they are incarcerated a
federal judge decided
so this up and down vote now was
meaningless in the end and recall that
prisoners have to buy their own
hygiene products they pay exorbitant
rates just to make
phone calls that's another big scam that
preys on prisoners which we've talked
about
give them the stimulus money guys we're
talking about stimulus money that went
to hundreds of millions of people
there's a couple million prisoners uh
that this that this applied to
let's not stand in the way but more
importantly tom cotton is such a
hypocrite
and his defense is so you know i
i want to say it's so obviously bogus if
it weren't for chris wallace saying whoa
whoa whoa stop the clock here
a lot of people probably would fall for
tom cotton's explanation and in fact
many people do because
they see chris wallace and they're like
that's like when shep smith was on fox
he's the one guy you can't trust on fox
news that's unfortunately the
perspective
of of many of these uh right-wing fox
viewers
but the talking point falls apart
so quickly and yet it still spreads like
wildfire so
nice job mostly by chris wallace this is
just kind of called journalism in many
other countries but i would have liked
to see him push back even more
one of the things that became super
clear during the last administration
was that so many of the things that the
right accused the left of doing
they were actually guilty of themselves
and we have a word for this this is
projection you project onto someone else
things about you you accuse others of
doing
things that you were doing and one of
those things
was that the left is rooting against
america
and this applied in a whole bunch of
different ways don jr
for example famously said a couple
months into coronavirus i don't remember
remember exactly when it was kind of i
think in that third quarter
of 2020 don jr said the left
and democrats are rooting against the us
on covid
democrats want people to die of covid
to make donald trump look bad and of
course it was completely untrue
there was no evidence of that but they
continue to insist they also would talk
about oh the left is rooting for russia
the left is rooting for china or the
left is rooting for europe or whatever
the case may be
things have now come full circle and in
the developing kerfuffle between
president joe biden and russian
president vladimir putin we're going to
talk about that more on the bonus show
fox news and republicans and
right-wingers are openly
rooting for vladimir putin now is that
patriotism
when they say america first when they
say pro-america
is this what they're talking about
openly rooting for vladimir putin
this started when joe biden referred to
vladimir putin as a killer
last week and then vladimir putin
challenged joe biden to a debate now
why foreign leaders would debate and
people wouldn't say
that doesn't make sense we'll talk about
in a little bit but let's look at some
clips
they're all rooting against the united
states here take a look at this first
clip of fox news propagandist sean
hannity
who does he sound like he's behind is he
rallying behind the american president
here no it doesn't sound like it
now question is this why would vladimir
putin immediately call
for a debate with joe biden no time to
prepare
what have i been saying what of some of
us half the american people saying the
media mob in this country
they protect all things radical
socialist joe biden
and his administration hannity defending
putin challenging biden to a debate if
it were trump
challenged by a foreign leader hannity
would say we're the united states
nobody challenges us no american
president needs to debate any foreign
leader we do whatever the hell we want
different situation right now here's
republican congressman matt gates
straight up saying this debate would be
all putin if it happened
putin and biden it would not end like
rocky
iv i don't think the american would
prevail
here's fox anchor harris faulkner
similar attitude
saying of course putin is going to
challenge biden
because biden hasn't even done a press
conference
at biden by the way doing a press
conference thursday which i will be
covering live here's harris faulkner
i can't help but think katie just a
quick follow-up with you
that this isn't also the determination
that how dare america talk to us about
free speech
when their own president won't go live
with free media like
how how you know what it does make us
look like we're hypocritical
so there are two layers of hypocrisy
here
first is the idea
that this is as simple as putin
versus biden on rhetorical skills
and none of them want to mention the
dramatically authoritarian nature of
putin
the poisonings the killings the fact
that putin
is accurately described as a killer by
joe biden
they're silent on that they won't even
concede none of them are saying
maybe putin would win a debate but joe
biden is right
putin is a killer but maybe the debate
would go putin's way
they won't even say that they don't even
acknowledge
the accurate critique of putin by joe
biden
acknowledging that doesn't mean we go to
war with russia i don't want a war with
russia
i don't know anyone who wants a war with
russia but then
here is the crowd that for years and
years during bush
during trump they say we are patriots
and we stand behind the president period
it's always america first never
second or third or anything and here
they are just saying yeah putin putin
putin no criticism of putin
not even saying biden's right even if
he's not a good debater biden is right
putin is a killer these people are
disgusting
but they're also hypocrites and we knew
both of those things all along
now one last thing i mentioned this
earlier
when has an american president ever
debated a foreign president
in particular at the demand of the
foreign leader what and what i mean by
that is
why are they even entertaining this on
the facts
they ran out of things about dr seuss i
guess if
any foreign leader had challenged trump
to a debate
they'd be saying an american president
owes
nothing to other world leaders no
american president should
devote a second of their time debating
another world leader
the goal posts aren't even in the same
stadium
when the president is a democrat as is
joe biden so
we're going to get the press conference
i'm as interested as anybody else to see
joe biden answer questions from the
press
in a more extended format that'll be
thursday don't know the time yet
but i will be covering it live on
youtube twitch and facebook i hope
you'll join me for that
and between now and then in the 72 hours
that remain
before joe biden's press conference uh
we will continue tracking what it used
to be dr seuss 24
7. now it's biden versus putin 24 7
on fox news we have a voicemail number
that you can call
absolutely anytime you want the number
is 219
to david p here's a question about our
old friend
rudy giuliani take a listen to this hi
this is jim from canada yeah and uh
i was wondering i was watching one of
your old episodes about rudy giuliani
right now uh back a year ago i was
wondering have you heard what's happened
to him lately
i mean last time i heard about a couple
of months ago
he was facing the possibility of uh
being debarred or whatever
from uh you know from a legal practice
yeah
he was going to have his lawyer's
license uh revoked
or taken away i'm just curious uh
any news about uh rudy lately
just curious have a good day keep up the
good work
so they're actually there is rudy news
first of all
over the last couple days news broke
that
uh rudy giuliani this is amazing rudy
giuliani tried to get
actor sasha baron cohen arrested for
extortion
over the entire borat 2 fiasco with
maria bakalova that we now know about
um rudy was suspended from youtube over
election fraud or fraud
uh he may be back on youtube now i'm not
i'm not totally sure but at one point he
was suspended and i actually
saw clips during that suspension of rudy
uh i i guess the clips must have been on
some other platform not youtube
rudy still talking as recently as about
seven to ten days ago
about the election being uh stolen from
him
by uh by joe biden stolen from trump
by joe biden and there is reportedly
a criminal investigation um
going on into rudy giuliani so that's
the latest with rudy giuliani
on today's bonus show we are going to
talk about
miami beach declaring a state of
emergency
over the absolute insanity of spring
break
crowds that have flocked there because
it's been
promoted as just being wide open it's
coveted freedom
as uh framed by many and we're going to
talk about this on the bonus show and
it's particularly funny because
as many of you know we're going to be on
the the show's taking a week off
next week and um i was actually
being fully vaccinated myself i was
actually thinking
with my girlfriend of driving to a beach
somewhere
and you know maybe south carolina but
south carolina's not really that warm
yet
in uh in march maybe florida i love
miami beach and then i saw
it's spring break hell it's covered hell
it's absolutely nuts
so we decided to go some somewhere else
i am going to be going somewhere else
but it's going to be a place that
requires testing for example to go and
and this type of thing
and so i tweeted about this over the
weekend saying i'm really glad
i made the decision not to go there and
some blue check checkmark right winger i
didn't even know who
who he was but you can you'll find this
if you look at my twitter
sort of like tweeted an attack on me
saying you're vaccinated
and you're still so afraid of something
that even for unvaccinated people has
like a one percent death rate that
you're still
not coming down to florida and within
like minutes of that tweet
florida declared a state of miami beach
declared a state of emergency and a
curfew
so yes it's less about will i as a
vaccinated person get sick
on the beaches of miami it's more about
it doesn't sound fun i don't want to go
and be
in a curfew situation with all sorts of
unvaccinated untested people
going completely crazy now that that's
not interesting to me and i felt like
instantly vindicated by my choice
as miami beach is now in a state of
emergency we will talk about that on the
bonus show that's a big lead up
we also will talk about the biden white
house staff
cannabis policy which just led to
some people being let go and we will
have more about this entire putin biden
debate idea with biden calling putin a
killer
and the coverage that it's received we
will also talk about that
and more on today's bonus show how do
you get access to the bonus show
um it's very easy you sign up at
joinpakman.com that's it
we have an unpublished new secret coupon
code i'm telling you but no one else
that code is immoral 21 all one word all
lower case
it's an immorally cheap discount i might
regret it
a year from now i might look back and
say that was disgusting when i offered
that coupon code
you can also simply become a patron on
patreon
at at least the five dollar a month
level
patreon.com davidpakmanshow show alright
i'll see everybody on the bonus show
and then tomorrow we're here this week
we're off next week and then we'll be
back
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary showerhead that
saves you money by using
45 less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman